the Army and Navy football teams fadeth
faceoff tomorrow in one of the biggest
rivalries in college football it will
air on CBS West Point cadet Simone askew
will lead the march of the US Military
Academy cadets she is the first black
woman to command the Corps of Cadets it
is a role previously held by General
Douglas MacArthur and four-star army
generals who currently command forces in
South Korea and Afghanistan first on CBS
this morning we introduce you to ask you
in our new series profiles in service
it's a look at people who dedicate their
lives to helping others we visited askew
at West Point to learn what inspires her
commitment to service the US Military
Academy is America's oldest service
Academy more than 200 years old but
never in its history has it had someone
like Simone askew at 21 she is the
highest ranking cadet at West Point
commanding a brigade of 4400 so you're
the only one with this amount of stripes
in this star exactly askew is the first
african-american woman selected to serve
as first captain of the Corps of Cadets
my focus now is really to be the best
first captain I can be regardless of
gender or race and that when the first
e-class graduates in May I'm remembered
as a good leader and not necessarily as
a good african-american female leader
and yet gender and race do set her apart
as the child of a white mom and a black
dad
askew says she often felt excluded
forces neared a young age to be okay
with my own sense of identity
so in all senses it was a positive thing
at West Point 22% of Cadets are women
and less than 4% are black women seeing
someone at least at the surface who you
can relate to provides a motivation for
some that person is Simone and for her
that person is Pat Locke it makes
everything that you do that you endure
worth it in 1980 Locke was one of the
first two African American women to
graduate from the Academy we've been
building to Simone for the last 35 years
you see so much of our nation in her the
way that she thinks the way that she
carries herself she knows she wants to
be a leader because she can make a
difference it's a dedication to service
ask you learned from her mom what does
service mean to you
definitely giving when there is not a
foreseeable benefit or beneficial
outcome to yourself so when did that
idea of selfless service come to you it
was definitely the example of my mom
Pam askew develops affordable housing
for primarily black communities in
Washington DC that is service to a
community that she doesn't receive
benefit from or at least initially does
not have any connection to and and
seeing her do that and be committed and
devoted to that was something I knew I
wanted to do when I grew up just to be
exactly like her
how much do you credit your mother with
where you are today about a hundred and
ten percent of it yeah I mean every
every single ounce of it my mom kept me
busy and she'll tell you it was to keep
me away from boys and out of trouble and
it worked she credits a big volleyball
tournament in high school with helping
her learn what she calls one of the most
important qualities of leadership
temperament it was down to maybe the
last game point
and I freaked out I didn't feel
comfortable we lost the game and I
accredited a lot of that to my inability
to remain calm and that lesson alone
among with many others taught me a lot
about what I've valued in leaders and
also the type of leader I wanted to be
now ask you says she's trying to be a
leader her fellow cadets deserve after
listening to you I keep thinking about
how temperament leads to performance
leads to success that's it yeah it's so
important because it sets a climate in
your own head but also in the atmosphere
around you making sure you make other
people feel comfortable it's really the
key to success and a lot of what we do
in the army because it is a people
business isn't she incredible and let me
just say this
Simone askew is also one of 32 American
students awarded the prestigious Rhodes
Scholarship this year to continue her
studies at the University of Oxford in
England and after that she says she's
going to stay in the military as long as
they will have her and for now today is
her 21st birthday so happy birthday does
she play the piano and make her own
clothes ever since biana when Nora came
back from this story you were raving
about Simone and now I so get it I love
what she said wanting to be the best
regardless of gender and race love her
and love her mom yeah you know you think
about there are so many great people who
are dedicated to the service of this
country every day yes and she's one of
them along with many others and she's
just such a bright leader I think for
our future yes she is for this country
but she said it's a people business or
president ask you anyone yeah I know I
was I can hear it
you can hear more of CBS this morning on
our podcast find them all on iTunes and
Apple's podcast app